- Have you ever had anything paranormal
happen to you in real life?
- Yeah, in my life,
okay so I'm from South Carolina,
you know, the south,
and there's a lot of things
in the south that don't
happen anywhere else,
you know, there's just
beliefs that they have,
things that they do, rituals.
When I was a kid, I
used to have this thing
that was sitting on my
chest when I would sleep
and it was keeping me from getting up
and I couldn't open my
eyes and I would struggle
and I couldn't breathe
very well, and I was like,
this is really, like it's scaring me.
And I would fight and struggle
and I would sit up in my bed,
and I'd look around and it would be
like someone was holding me down, I swear.
And I'd tell my mom about it.
It would happen night after night.
And as soon as I lay down,
it would happen again,
it's like holding me
and I was like, I couldn't open my eyes.
It was scaring me.
So we talked about it--
- What?!
- Yeah.
She said it was, it was this thing called,
it was like a hag.
It was called a hag.
And it would ride you
because your spirit was unsettled.
- Ha!
Okay.
(laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
She told me.
And there was this old woman
living across the street from me.
And I would talk about her all the time,
because she lived alone,
and she was freaky,
and she'd never come outside.
So, me and all my cousins
in the neighborhood,
we were afraid of this woman.
So I think, she's, my mom says,
because of your,
the way you're thinking about this woman
and she's, her spirit is riding,
this is the thing that they
do and she had that power.
That's like a witch!
- That's creepy and I'm sorry.
- Yeah.
- I know, I know.
I'm still dealing with that right now.
I sleep with lights on.
- That would terrify me!
- Yeah.
- If I couldn't move.
- I know.
I know.
- Oh my gosh.
- Okay, another favorite
thing about you though,
you have a tiny dog, do
you have it to protect you?
It's a tiny dog.
- No, no, no, no.
- You're just a big man with a tiny dog.
It's awesome.
(audience screaming)
It's like, it's funny.
It's so cute!
- That, listen that picture says it all.
My dog, listen I didn't
get the dog on my own,
that wasn't my choice, but
I just feel like, you know,
I don't need a dog to
protect me, I protect my dog.
That's how I look at it.
My dog is a small dog and I hold my dog.
And if I see another dog, I pick it up.
It's, you know,
(audience clapping)
I'm protecting my dog.
That's how I look at it.
- Oh my god!
You think other guys
might be overcompensating?
- I think they are.
- Like, look at my big dog?
- They got two, they got two pit bulls
and you're like pulling in the street,
and you're like yeah, you know, yeah.
(laughing)
I'm like, really?
Really?
You have two?
- I love, I love it.